hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
I'm really dumb you guys were probably
yelling at me very loudly wow I was
playing it uneasy I thought I was
playing it on hard or normal
I am very stupid so now now I thought it
was really easy so now we're gonna be
playing the hundred Mario challenge on
normal and hopefully this is going to be
a bit more of a challenge than last time
and I'll be able to show off my
incredible skill but now I realize if I
died six or seven times uneasy whew if I
get to expert it's not gonna be too good
for me but that's besides the point we
got our army of clones and we're ready
to go also didn't realize I was wearing
my headphones last time I don't need to
wear because they're coming through the
oh my god I'm okay
my stomach is just about to explode all
right let's do this
who's here want some cause hard well
[ __ ]
lost that already that's too bad I'm too
good for this too good for this world
and a lot of things well if this is what
normal is I'm gonna be [ __ ] why didn't I
get the 1up [ __ ] I mean poop fudge god
dingus crap hole monkey butter
I don't know keep going keep going gotta
go go go go next XX let's see let's goes
go go go go okay we got sixteen levels
to go through this time which is going
to be a bit more of a challenge because
there's twice as many before it if you
didn't know common math that's how that
works alright anyway hello thank you Oh
what oh what am i Solid Snake what am i
hiding from here what what about just a
box Oh God hello hello hello oh god lost
that [ __ ] well hi how's it going oh I
want this please boink
thank you okay goodbye oh my god oh my
god oh my God where did you come from
it was right there
damn it okay we're fine we got this
school is
it's cool Miku you cou I cou we all cou
we all be okay okay whoa hello
Oh boink boink [ __ ] Oh God okay we're
fine
[ __ ] okay we're still fine apparently Oh
God
you know what let's just forget about
that forget about that scope here I
didn't even get the 1up but I'm fine I
should have gotten the 1up it's an easy
one up can replace your clothes with one
of us but I'm not doing it cuz I am in a
fluster hi I'm in a tizzy this time okay
but I'm gonna speed through these
because I'm a demon I know I got the
world record on another one last time
but knowing that the reason course is
gonna Rob the meaning from me okay here
we go Oh No this to me I'm barely
getting started here oh boy yeah yeah
[ __ ] okay so oh oh wow how am I supposed
to do this how is this supposed to be
doing okay the secret of this is it's no
secret at all you're just supposed to
move forward no it's fine hey don't
don't patronize me I'm fine I'm just
turning to the right I'm not timing
these jumps or anything because there's
no jumps to time because if you jump you
will hit the spikes and you will die so
I'm assuming I'm just supposed to keep
do dad yep yep yep yep yep
give me the clones give me the clones it
matches you at three one ups per I guess
point point
this fart this like really fun it was
legitimately fun I love this this is
awesome I love this oh it's so cool I
was off the world record because there's
nothing ability to do about that one cuz
you're just pressing right nothing
really special so world record or not
it's not too special okay what do we got
what the hell am I supposed to go I
think I think it wants me to go up there
I'm not ever since sure and okay okay
gonna do here right here okay here there
we go
oh what's this what is this what is this
crap what is this what is this was I
supposed to come up here I'm only
assuming so I really hope that just in
one of these isn't the magical secret
exit to the mushrooms oh gosh oh oh
where am I now
hello hi okay we did it what the hell's
with that level oh my god that's so cool
alright anyway I could have gotten the
world record on that one if I have known
where to go right from the beginning of
the game but I did not cuz I had no idea
what was happening that me that was
staring at me was not pretty
oh I didn't know that there was a super
mario maker amiibo cool where the hell
am I going this seems like a confusing
mess oh boy
okay god I'm gonna oh god I'm gonna be
lost forever I'm gonna be wandering the
what is this I'm gonna go on the top one
what the hell is this supposed to be oh
no oh no okay I can figure this out I
think I went through this one yeah I
went through this one before and there's
no other way around this one so none of
these doors must be correct so this goes
back here this goes nowhere
so then storage just pops out the other
side of this door so those doors just go
to each other
well I'm lost I think I need to restart
because I must have done something wrong
yeah
well that's sad music what can I get
back to the game now no it just drops me
here doesn't particularly make a lot of
sense oh oh oh I know I know I know okay
so I was looking at it the wrong way
there's got to be okay so it's a series
of mechanisms that I need to activate
from the outside okay oh here we are
ahahaha okay so it all starts with this
guy but he's got a how does he get out
that is the big question
ah oh there we go okay okay okay we
started something oh we got something
okay ah
and then buzzy beetle is gonna go over
there and that's gonna do something over
somewhere else probably above that's
probably why I was over there oh it
probably did something over here ooh
but what damn it I'm not a hum person
sure what it did though okay so it's
back now okay so pink and then that
explodes that which has allows that to
go off boink
I'm bleeding I'm a beetle boom boom ba
boo boo
okay so what did that do this is no
because that was not a block then okay
so let me see what it does when the fire
goes over here uh-huh okay so that goes
over there so he goes back okay
eventually it's gonna get on yeah on the
thing so he's on the thing ow
so he goes over there okay but he
finally made it so what did that do what
are those things doing I'm not a harbor
sense sure I understand what's going on
when those things are moving not crap
that ain't good well I have no idea what
I was supposed to be doing so I guess
I'll just try this for myself oh god
damn it but now that da the mole man
okay go damn it damn it damn it damn it
okay I don't know I don't know how to do
that one I don't know it's taking me way
too long my objective is to get halfway
through this challenge and then pick up
the other half in another episode I'm
gonna do that because that way I don't
drive myself absolutely bonkers insane
Oh what am I supposed to do here what am
I even looking at how do I do this
ah okay bit confused is there a secret
block here that I'm not sure am I
supposed to throw myself headfirst into
the saw blades maybe there's some clue
the clue just says thanks guys
no I'm not your father that doesn't help
me at all ah okay oh okay
No ah found you found you found you
found you found you okay I got what I
needed
boy thank you okay what the hell is it
looks like Mega Man inspired bull I
don't know if I was supposed to open
this or not probably am because I don't
think I can break that without it shout
thank you knowing I'm an expert there we
go got it gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta
got it okay give me the boot ah Frick I
don't know if I need to that I probably
needed that to be able to break stuff
wait am I supposed to oh okay so I got a
spring can I should I keep the spring so
I need the boot and I need to be big
because I need to be able to get through
here
bam bam bam thank you ma'am Bam Bam Bam
Bam through the clear the pine no okay
then my other idea was more correct that
out of feather I just saw a feather
flown now from that hell wouldn't give
me the feather before why did it give me
the feather then thank you I guess
gotta help me somehow okay so now I know
what I need to do I need 200 little
lately so now my original idea was to go
here yeah okay yeah there we go okay got
it so now I got this and I can put the
spring literally I can put the spring aw
crap
almost almost almost almost almost yes
okay
did that got it how am I gonna do this
what the hell is this supposed to be oh
wait no I've forgotten I'm got the tail
okay got it
okay got it go down this it's all about
if this isn't oh okay I think I was
supposed to use this spring for
something else and now I need the whoops
well that's a thing
okay then still very confused as to what
my end goal is am I supposed to well now
I got a fashionable helmet ain't that
delightful back up to a hundred men I
love it when I have a hundred man oh oh
that's nice
okay I'm gonna do one more I'm gonna do
one more of these for this episode and
then I'm gonna be moving on we'll record
for 54 seconds I'm not even coming close
to touching that so I'm not even gonna
have any hope for myself oh wait no yeah
yeah I'll do one more probably in the
next episode I'll go way faster on this
I'll actually finish it out though Oh
what do you got for me all depends on
how many like super easy ones instant
finisher thank you they immediately knew
that I was gonna [ __ ] it up so or fudge
it up fudge it up fudge it up fudged up
trying to I'm trying to I've noticed
that I said [ __ ] I sit I say [ __ ] a lot
more frequently than I have in the past
and try to be better about it for no
other reason I'm not even trying to be
PG about it for the kiddies I'm just
saying like oh thank you thank you thank
you I'm just saying it for my own
personal reasons I want to be more
clever than just always cursing all the
time so
it's it's very easy to be vulgar that's
one thing that that's evident in
comedies and I'm not even saying this is
about comedy this is just me and my
personal things it's very easy to be
vulgar it's not always easy to try to be
some sort of clever crap oh god oh god
oh god he's getting a little dangerous I
don't like this yeah what is those have
I ever seen those crap crap crap crap
dammit don't know what happened what's
up there what's up there whoa are you
fine god damn it I didn't know there was
gonna be no floor alright next clone up
get ready for the chopping block it's
gonna be messy it's gonna be brutal
crap yeah but I was gonna I gotta throw
that crap crap hole crap bag grab ass
[ __ ] god dammit oh fudge me find your
own e pizza by the last one I was the I
am the one who boinks not them well
let's try do this properly didn't even
know the cell as a platform there there
we go isn't that supposed to be a fire
flower didn't that doesn't that isn't
that what I got earlier maybe it's
through here and I just forgot about
everything
you know you've been playing games too
long that you forget instantly where you
are and what you're doing in life and
you're 26 years old and already at a
loss ah operate conquer eight got create
on me don't ask me what that means shut
up it's the stupid wall jump like the
wall jump isn't a part of any other
Mario so when it's in here it's just
very disorienting
okay so supposedly there's going to be
hidden things hidden it stupid no there
we go got it okay so that is almost a
half of the hundred Mario challenge that
took me a while just because I was spent
so long on the level that I couldn't do
but that is the all for this episode
that is all the time I got for this
episode I will return to this very soon
to finish out the normal level of 100
Mario Super Mario challenge or button
Mauri Mauri amaur amaur amaur amaur
Mario and I'll finish up the expert one
once I beat the normal one so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
what this are to change direction BRR
it's cold I need to get out of here so
I've got my is that my breath